one of the finest at his positions last
time we saw him on the field he was
knocking a ball loose to preserve a a
victory for the minnesota vikings the uh
all-pro safety and defensive back
harrison smith here on the rich eisen
show how are you harrison
i'm doing great thanks for having me on
richard thanks for going us how is
everything in in the vikings world in
this crazy coveted 19 world have things
changed around there for the team what's
going on there
the protocols have just been kind of
enhanced um like they are around the
league so um you know trying to keep
keep the meetings virtual and uh you
know the contact
uh
limited
uh masks and everything just like
everybody else okay so um walk me
through your
um your guys season in terms of
where you feel you are and where you
have been harrison i know that's a very
wide open question but the the vikings
are a team that could be a one seed
right now based on all the games that
you had wrapped seemingly or were in uh
as opposed to where you are right now
harrison yeah it's uh it's it's
definitely the wildest i've been a part
of as as far as close games go you know
you you kind of talk about it every year
everyone talks about it's one play here
or there but this has been uh
definitely
the
the most uh kind of aggressive version
of that every game is
field goal touchdown at the end
something um
so yeah you can look at it and say we
could we could have done this okay on
that but
you are here we are we're six and seven
and we still still have what we want in
front of us so we're still in control of
that do you have any conversations at
all about closing games like
specifically and if so what how how how
do you have a conversation about that
sort of thing yeah we do and um
you know one place we've struggled on on
defense this year is uh two minute
whether it's into the first half into
the second half and you know that's what
a lot of games come down to uh
team that scores normally wins a team
that doesn't play great defense doesn't
um so that's that's one thing we've
we've talked about and the scenarios are
different every week it's not just just
one conversation um
you know the time is always the fact of
the timeouts are you up are you up a
field goal or you have a touchdown so
there's always
some things that can change and are
always different every week
we're just
trying to uh correct that aspect from a
defensive standpoint well what is it is
it a communication thing is that what
you discuss is that what it is where you
that's part of it okay it's it's it's
everything it's uh you know that's why
that's why football's uh such a good
good game to watch um
so much goes into it the gameplay the
players
um
you know like i said all all the the the
timeouts and
formations and checks and all those
things so uh communication i would say
is is always at the top of the list yeah
because again like it's not your choice
when to call timeouts you know what i
mean like so obviously you can't control
all of that
and i don't mean i don't mean just
calling them though i mean like how many
does the offense have last
we have left
um what you know where's the ball
uh how's the flow of the game going all
that stuff
right and that's why i'm trying to just
drill down to something concrete that
you say okay we fixed that we fixed that
and we can fix our issues but
that that's
you know why i'm i'm wondering if it's a
communication like if if they're quick
snapping you and you guys might not be
set because there's x y and z going on
that's i guess the way i'm trying to
game it out with you here harrison you
know yeah there's just
that might happen one time and then
there might be another issue that
happens really time that's
that's how the game goes well i guess
the last two second defense was pretty
damn good from you this last time out
he kind of got that one all worked out
uh walk me through that last play that
kind of saved the day uh for your team
that was up 29 nothing before all that
harrison yeah um
obviously like in in this instance we
know that time is no longer it doesn't
really exist anymore it's one play no
matter what um
so really in in that scenario just kind
of reading the quarterback and
kind of knowing knowing where he might
go with it
um
and then and then xavier woods on the
other side had a good break as well and
kind of
didn't let the tight end kind of fall
away so
kind of both had a bang bang on the ball
and and got it out
who's the toughest quarterback to read
harrison in the nfl for you
man there's a lot of those ben ben uh
had a great second half against us and
he was
he was um you know looking looking us
off on the back end and stuff like that
making great throws it's it it's always
easy for me to to go with rogers because
we see him twice a year right
i wouldn't say anyone's better than he
is at that um there's a lot of good guys
around the league but he's a
pretty top shelf for stafford through a
staffer threw a no look on me last year
um which like people probably didn't
even see on tv but like right after the
play i was like man that was that was
nice
you gotta give it up sometimes right you
gotta give it up sometimes
they're good they're good what are you
gonna do well you're the one that they
circle more often than not harrison so
uh hearing it from you is is obviously
uh a big-time kudo but so what does
rogers do like all these guys do they're
they're they're staring at somebody they
have no intention of throwing it to and
you're it's your job to not take that
bait or know that uh that these are the
guys who would never stare at a receiver
let's i'm like how do you game it when
you see that stuff
for you well sometimes they'll throw
right where they're looking and
sometimes they're setting you up
some of it's pre-snap
[Music]
you know i kind of move around a lot
pre-snap and try to
try to make it a little tougher on on
them and the offensive line with
protections and things sometimes and um
you know so
some of that is a pre-snap pre-snap game
uh which is which is kind of fun
um and then once once the play starts
yeah there's only so much time you know
you've got the d-line rushing and
things can fall apart so there's only so
much time they can look you off but
these guys are very good at it well i
mean i don't mean for you to give up
your trade secrets even though i guess i
was just asking for a couple this week
though you're taking on a kid
uh who has an incredible amount of
talent certainly when he escapes the
pocket certainly when maybe he he can um
run some play action your way
what about justin fields this week for
you
harrison smith what about this kid yeah
like you mentioned he's he's a young guy
um
he's extremely talented um
can can extend plays with his legs and
and has a big arm
obviously he doesn't have a ton of
wrecks in the nfl
so you know whenever you go against a
young guy you obviously
want to make it tough on him but
there's a reason he's there there's a
reason he's drafted so you know we
understand the
ability he brings to the table harrison
smith uh pro bowler all pro right here
on the rich eisen show from the
minnesota vikings i'll just ask you
point blank you know it's not your first
rodeo here on the program and you know i
i i i'll just ask you straight out uh do
you think you're playing for mike
zimmer's job do you guys feel that way
in your locker room right now
harrison um
i don't know from like a consensus
standpoint but you know
it's kind of the reality um
pretty much every year
every player is playing for their job
uh even if you sign
you sign a new deal or whatever like
we all know how it really is in the nfl
they're not we all have guaranteed
contracts it only takes a year or two
for you to be out
so everyone's always playing for their
job everyone's always coaching for their
job so
that um
yeah i mean that's just how it is
and in terms of your playoff spot do you
feel like every game is your playoff
spot and positioning's on the line at
the very least
for you guys yeah absolutely yeah
i mean this is it and this is a big game
man for sure before i let you go
harrison smith um before i let you go
what do you think of brian kelly leaving
uh your alma mater for lsu what'd you
think about that i bet you like that
didn't you well you know
from the michigan guy
yeah i'm just asking uh because
part of you know this is my world right
now you're paying rent and you know what
i'm saying like it's it's great you know
um yeah but you know it did it did you
know i i i do like marcus freeman and
what he uh is appearing to bring to the
table but i'm just wondering what it was
for you uh to watch brian kelly go to
another school what'd you think of that
one yeah i was i was surprised um
i would have been surprised if you know
any coach leaving a a big time program
for another big time program like in in
you know what seems to be
you know he's doing well he didn't get
fired or anything it's just you don't
see that a lot although we've seen it
this year a couple times um
so it was surprising but um
you never know what people's
personal goals are and stuff so
i don't i don't have any i don't have
any ill will towards him i hope he does
well down there and
i hope freeman does well and uh at notre
dame i i was really hoping for somehow
some type of michigan notre dame match
up in the playoffs but
yeah yeah wait no
for that one no i know i know harrison
that would have required um you know
either cincinnati to have lost or
or georgia to have beaten alabama and
the way it turned out is michigan
winning denied notre dame a seat at the
table um i'm just spitting facts now um
you know i'm just a fact spitter right
now but
uh i did what did you think it did did
you hear uh kelly address the uh the
crowd at the basketball game in lsu did
you see did you see that one i saw i saw
the highlight or the low light
look at it um yeah he's trying to fit in
man
he's had success everywhere he's been
you don't know about the accident but
he'll be fine i don't know maybe he was
watching the water boy on the flight
down right you know what i've heard that
some guys in the locker room were
talking about that
they worked in the water boy
i don't know people were screaming from
the stands that he could do it you know
what i mean maybe that's what was going
on i don't know
but yeah so what do you what do you
think of the wolverines what what do you
think when you watch college football
i don't watch a ton
but i will say i i enjoyed watching them
play um play ohio state i thought they
played with a lot of energy and uh i
liked how their defense played
you don't you don't always see a ton of
a ton of great defense in
college games but there's guys flying
around there so yeah even though it's
michigan and
all right you know got some bad memories
in michigan the big house no no
it's fun to watch it's okay everything's
turned off everything's turned out fine
yeah i'm kind of sick of the sec
dominance so let's go right let's go i
wouldn't mind seeing michigan
i don't know if i want to see him win at
all but
i don't know if you're probably a
cincinnati guy at this point you know
does your quarterback before that's
about to say does your quarterback feel
the same way does he feel the same way i
imagine so i imagine he would not want
you to even is he rooting for the big
ten come on now he's got to be at least
rooting for the bigger team he might be
he's a
big ten guy he might he might you know
put his sparty ways aside for you
yeah tell him i said hi will you tell
him i sent him yeah i will
and anybody else from ohio state or iowa
i'm literally i'm literally writing
checks right now and it's amazing i'm
talking with my chest my guys here are
very proud of me you gotta be careful
about what
this is house money now i should go to
vegas this is amazing this is house
money now harrison you know how it works
this is great this is what happened this
is what happened with notre dame they
went they went to the playoffs and
didn't have their best showings right
and then people were like notre dame
never belongs again so right oh daniel i
don't feel like i'm going down that road
i don't i don't feel that way all i know
is i'm greatly appreciative of you being
here and uh happy holidays to you and
your family
happy holidays thanks for having me on
take care harrison
harrison smith everybody right here on
the rich eisen show from the minnesota
vikings
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here